james charles where are you we have to
play minecraft
my sister hi sister
team sister fister is back in business
team sister mr
is back and we're gonna win this time
are we i've taken over the minecraft
universe i can't
first there's the beauty world now it's
minecraft but it's the entire world
you're gonna have to help me get my very
first
kill in hunger games minecraft today um
okay i feel like let's just jump
right in then shall we let's just jump
into it yeah no okay do you want to do
it let's do og
or we can do either minecraft monday
snail or og it's up to you wait wait
wait i feel like i have to tell people
the bros because the bros might not know
that
james charles is an epic minecraft gamer
you have to carry me here because like
i'm terrible okay okay
because we already played on the
minecraft mondays but they didn't
you know it could have gone better oh
hey well
maybe if you didn't die within the first
three seconds every time
what okay i feel like we should like
okay so for those of you guys who don't
know
felix and i played on this fun
tournament called minecraft monday a few
weeks ago together
team showed out ended up winning in the
end but it was a challenge
and did end up winning no no no no no no
no no no
we have to be honest we didn't play our
best let's just yeah
no we don't have to be okay so we are
going to run
um where are you where are you james
okay i see you
we're directly across you're going to
see you're going to run to your left
towards the barn
oh i see you okay just right left
there's no barn oh i see it okay okay
okay run that way they recognize me
they're all looking at me i don't like
this
your skin isn't disguised for some
reason i think you didn't put on
disguise well correctly
damn it okay just go this warrant
someone hit me james
oh i'm first standing it doesn't open
james i have a weapon i have a weapon
where are you right here i'm so scared
where are you stop they're punching me
where are you i don't i went to the barn
james
what barn did you i got a chest i got a
chest don't worry
no way i don't have a chat where did you
go you said go let you said go left
i yes and i went left where did you go
okay okay i'm by the weird windmills
thing okay i know where you are
basically in the back of the map there's
a bunch of like teepees all together
i need to get to those okay this is the
longest i've ever been alive
yeah i'm so proud
don't be scared i already died oh this
guy this guy just gave me a helmet
thank you he gave me
how could they kill james charles no no
don't even you know what are you still
in the game
yes i'm still in the game i'm killing it
we need to disguise you so people can't
follow you off the spawn
oh that's why i didn't see you yeah you
were disguised
yeah that's the point james
there's no time i don't know where to go
okay
i'm going for chests in the middle i
don't see you no don't go for tests in
the middle
oh my god to your left to your left to
your left
left left left just walk out just walk
out like get out
oh yeah oh god these guys oh i see i see
it i'm right behind you
great okay this is the game james
okay i have one ready you have a weapon
you have two weapons okay
kill him kill him he's got dantd james
it's okay let's okay go go
yeah don't worry i'll tank them there's
a chest up here
[Music]
frick i died this is so sad
wow
so i'm james charles fan x oh
my god felix do you find
i see your friend right here i'm right
here
huh right here right here are you the
baby i am the baby
eww okay so in this map okay see over
this way right here see how there's like
that like white
hut i see it behind okay there's a lot
of people let's go baby
so okay so it's that white building
right there um there's a chest in this
building over here i know for sure
okay there's a weapon heck yeah let's go
this way all right we're going back
oh god he has an iron sword ah okay iron
sword run james charles
i'm running oh he's chasing us of course
he is that's
others don't worry james charles i'll
freak him up
do i have to punch the tnt oh whoa whoa
whoa
that was a pro gamer move oh
get him james i can't i'm literally on
two hearts get him james
where are you i'm right behind you
i'm gonna blow into smithereens frick
for
we're so bad okay this we're going felix
this way don't turn around turn around
i'm right here okay we're going this way
towards the hut
it's behind the this hill okay i'm
nearby where we're going
do i go to the red barn or not uh yes go
to the red barn behind that
cactus that's like straight back behind
you there's a chest if you want to
run right to it and grab it the fake
characters like the but i'm ready to
break oh i see the fake heck there yeah
there's a
yeah there's um a chest behind me if you
want to grab it
just go like like back towards the edge
of the mouth are you by the pumpkins and
stuff yeah
yes how do you know where everything is
okay i'm gonna give you this helmet wait
come here spit it out okay now we're
gonna win
i got a melon and a helmet okay let's
cross the river
oh we can get the double chest too okay
is that you that's running towards me
oh no it's not okay felix okay there's
somebody over here where are you
oh i'm in the other building i'm in the
other building
get him james
okay sister feisty
why did you get disconnected i don't
know
the minecraft gods are not happy okay
all right where are you
okay i was just we're going directly
behind where i am right now so where are
okay i see it where are all the chests
in this stupid game i found one
[Music]
okay behind you behind you james charles
frick come up
i fell in what wait felix where'd you go
wait you died yeah you dancing [ __ ]
dancing [ __ ]
i've been i haven't i'm going to be
honest i haven't been trying my hardest
time i'm trying my hardest
okay great damn girl was that you no i
am
damn [ __ ] damn [ __ ] sorry get a chest
as fast as you possibly can
dude i got a bow but no arrows this is
bull crap okay got another chest
come on okay are you [ __ ] in the hill
okay
this is me this is me right here damn
[ __ ] is gonna die
die
oh you're gonna get gamed on you're
gonna get him get him get to felix
you're gonna get game done you're gonna
get game dawg they're so fast how are
they so fast
gamer stop pushing me
oh excuse me i keep forgetting that i'm
supposed to spam there just run house
down run past them go up the hill
no they're dead okay this is a good i
okay we're in the right area
[Music]
are you kidding me i have an axe and
they don't die what is this game
oh felix okay so literally we're gonna
go this way there's a
james when you say this way i have no
idea what you're talking about okay okay
so this is me right here in front of you
okay so we're going the same exact way
that we did last time right so put that
cap
okay there's a chest behind there and
then we go over that hill to the left
towards the bottom and then right when
you get
like over this little hill right here
hug
the left of this mountain where's the oh
dude i'm right by the cactus
it's gamer on oh god i didn't go for the
chest i'm forgotten it's okay just go to
okay yeah go go no i get the chest it's
my chest oh dude i got leather pants
james charles now stayed in the left
right here i'm right here behind you go
through that
tower or that like doorway
okay i have a sword good yes commander's
gonna go for the same thing keep going
yup keep going no keep going this is me
but i always lose you
all right he already has boots prepared
to die [ __ ]
we need to get your weapon first i have
a weapon for you felix
i died no why do i die so fast
get him james i can't it's lagging oh my
god
you did it okay are you spectating me
yeah i guess i'll spectate do you want
me to comment
no you don't have to it's fine oh my god
wow i can't believe you're living quite
feelings you suck
james charles just said i suck at
minecraft this is the worst day of my
life
isn't it fun playing with me we get to
play for two seconds
i thought maybe like we were bad because
uh minecraft money is like wow
i think i'm the best there ever was
james
leave the game fine are you the one
jumping
yes i'm jumping yes okay so you go
directly to your left
because the white thing that thing is
right there the thing is right there
okay i got a weapon i got a weapon
okay where do i go james to that
building that i said about last time
i have absolutely no memory james
charles okay i have a weapon
right here oh there you are i found
james okay this is the good building
get the chest as well as you can
grab a weapon i don't have a freaking
weapon
okay
okay stay right here stay right here
stay in here okay so i have hands
okay um here take this
oh wait take this you have a weapon
quickly get him jake just let him go let
him go let him go let him go okay
there's a guy right here
oh that's like that account
kill him no no no no no
and it was a james charles fan account i
just killed
you killed him you stole you stole kill
james charles okay let's go let's go
no no no no no i'm not brushing over
this hey i look like ultimate account
here take these oh you already have
boots okay what do you need uh we both
need better chest plates
okay this person right there let's go oh
that's my fan account two
freak your fan account james carl
james charles kills fans
that's a video title okay we need to get
more items
really oh there's somebody over here
there's somebody over here you go to the
left i go right
oh wow he's good oh god he's good he's
terrible
he's terrible stop don't die don't die
he's terrible
[Music]
get him jake
what what hacks ban
disrespectful disrespect disrespectful
i almost got a kill though so i think uh
this is good we're improving my own fan
account all right we need to find more
of your fans to kill them james
okay now go to your left your left your
left
oops there's no chests it's rigged oh
wait that's my own fan account again
okay where are you
this is a murderer you're good you're
dead
yes yes yes you're awful
i'm sorry it had to be done wow
dude there's a chest here how do i get
that oh i get it
lift me up she can jump oh that guy's
gonna get up shoot okay feel like we're
gonna break
uh okay i'll throw snowballs on there oh
he's really bad oh just kidding well i'm
gonna die
you're bad you're bad [ __ ] you're bad
ah
james james help help don't talk
help james jones where are you go this
way this way i'm on
what ah james did you fall into the trap
did joe's help me felix james don't help
me please i'm dying
i have a sword i'm a sword i have a
sword
are you falling into the trap
that's such a
[Music]
okay that was good that was a good game
no i got it killed
i gotta kill him stop killing my fan
accounts
i'll kill as many fan accounts as i
goddamn pleases
damn these games are hardcore i know i
want to talk okay right here keep going
keep going
okay now i'm right here in front of you
to your left here left left tail left
okay i have a weapon for you
where are you yes where are you i went
right behind
i got a kill okay where are you yes
i'm hiding until i find you i'm in this
big big big big
big big very big large building
with no freaking loot in it um go back
out to spawn
okay i'll oh okay i got a stick and
sugar and raw beef
i think we got this okay
i don't think so i don't think so james
back up back up james
got him got him got it got him got him
got him you got him
yeah yes james charles
this is good this is what i'm talking
about oh my fan account is done okay
let's look for chess
i'm i'm on i'm on three out three health
yeah one melon we'll do one melon with
this oh there's another chest
oh okay i have a song for you
i have it's axe okay that's the same
thing here just take the sword instead
because it's a little bit better
that's not better but it just it's
easier to hit with in my opinion oh yeah
james charles we are almost top ten
oh hey this is true let's go down we are
gonna win this
how i love this auditory feel here are
items so somebody was here oh there's
some right there right there
turn our turnaround turn around he's got
freaking fire
shoot oh no he just ender pearled away
avenge me he's going to end up
come on james
yes yes
james church should i keep playing are
you gonna spectate here should i yeah
you're gonna
keep playing oh win oh wait he trash
talked this city
you suck kid almost killed you tim he
dot okay bye
he will find out it got killed by james
charles oh
and it was recorded on youtube got him
your top 10 james you're already amazing
wow thank you so much you're doing so
good you're so good at minecraft freak
him up
there's no toys more like so
no toes
[Music]
he's got dnt james
that was close he's literally
leaving tnt and i'm not even anywhere
near him he's eating cake james
i don't have any arrows he's put spider
web be careful
nice you can't play james charles like
that
no one plays james charles like that
james dogs
[Music]
did an epic let's go no
oodle more like no schnoodle
come on come on they're teaming wait
that's cheating
they're ranging they rant they're what
are you doing
golden apple time okay all right we're
pulling out the big guns oh oh james
charles got arrows hit two times
james charles running away james charles
oh he do he went in the water
he freaked up i can go and chance and
make my sword stronger that's
i was i was just about to say yes he
looks like i could win this
this is good this is good this is good
james they're this is it this is the
moment he goes in
2v1 he's on fire he's on fire
oh he missed oh he missed keep getting
him
one is right behind you and the other's
on your right no
no wait you're still alive oh i thought
you died
stop teaming you have virginity whoa
true
how do they know james i don't know how
is that the other guy
wait where are they right behind you
where's the other guy i don't know shoot
okay he locked he's diverted oh there's
three people in this area
that guy has a diamond sword okay i
could win this somehow
i said don't fight me fight the team no
why are you kidding me behind you games
okay good this is my this is my time
go james charles no
oh yes yes behind him i know
uh oh
[Music]
james
oh god oh he's far away
okay i took them both on felix
that was pro gamer
oh i have two tokens oh my god
you make the diamond shoulder james
jones oh it's death match
oh god james why are you doing that
focus okay okay you can do this oh he's
trapped by the tnt oh he's low he's low
james charles james charles james
charles james charles oh
god
oh my god james charles is about to
sacrifice
one of his most loyal sisters
we have gathered here today thank you
for your sister service
this is so dark you're gonna burn sister
you're burning
my sister's still alive wait i'll push
her in
i'll bury you it's a sign from
god
[Music]
[Applause]
what a trooper
that's a true sister right sister she is
a real one
we'll win this one james let's just
communicate
let's do this easy win come on okay
all right so we have one felix this
actually might be an easy win
all right let's get it where are you
where are you are you
i'm right here
[Music]
i got it i got it
[Applause]
[Music]
is
oh i see all right no i couldn't do that
i couldn't i could have just killed
james charles
i'm not fighting you i've never never
killed a gamer
wait wait wait for real
[Music]
james charles oh my god
i'm so i'm so glad we finally won the
game
damn sister guys check out
james charles link in description
he's a real gamer as you can see
give this video a thumbs up if you want
felix to get his makeup done
we're making it happen
[Music]
i didn't i didn't catch what you said
but yes rate this a thumbs up
good sounds good you don't need to hear
us okay